this video is sponsored by keeps which
means you will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone welcome to another gaming
q a i do one of these a month and then i
do q and a's for anything not related to
gaming on a second channel i'll leave a
link in the description below if you
want to ask a question for the next one
leave it in the comments the first one
i'm going to talk about because i got
comments about this people asking me
questions about this across multiple
videos um and i'm i do find it very
interesting so in case you missed it on
twitter the for spoken account for
spoken is a game you've probably seen in
some of the showcases coming out in
january of 2023 from square enix
their twitter account tweeted this
trailer that um is bat it's only 30
seconds long it has three million views
so their marketing is certainly popping
off and of course i think there are
large facets of people who are being
like unreasonably toxic about how bad it
is and like way too angry about it and
it's blown up into this whole thing but
i'm not gonna defend the trailer it's
bad
and i have very specific reason why i
think it's bad so let me just show it to
you first in case you haven't seen it uh
this is direct from their twitter
the caption says a beautiful and cruel
new land twisted monsters an array of
magical abilities sentient jewellery
welcome to the world of forspoken
so let me get this straight
i'm somewhere that's not what i would
call earth
i'm seeing freaking dragons and oh yeah
i'm talking to a cop
[Music]
yeah okay that is something i do now
i do magic hill jacked up beast
i'll probably fly next
so here's what i really wanted to talk
about i was excited to talk about it a
lot of the criticism is people
complaining about the writing and
complaining about the voice acting i
definitely don't think the voice acting
is an issue here this voice actress is
doing her best with
no material i think the issue with this
trailer
um which is more of a spot than a
trailer it is only 30 seconds is
the tone is so far off you have this
woman saying so let me get this straight
i have this and this and what she's
saying is oh my god i can't believe this
thing is happening but then the footage
you're seeing is so milk toast and
actually i think the gameplay in this
game looks pretty cool it's it's the
disconnect that makes this so
bad and i also think that it really
sells your protagonist short because
when you have your protagonist
marketing the game and not just
marketing themselves like if you're
gonna have a trailer about a protagonist
you would do it in the way that um
gotham knights is an example of right
now
where
they have snippets of each character
what it's like to play each character
where each character is emotionally this
is your protagonist like a sales pitch
trying to convince you of things that
are cool without ever showing you
that the thing is cool so there's a
massive awkward disconnect like if
somebody's going i'm talking to a cuff
and then all you actually see is just a
visual zoom in of some [ __ ] wristband
type jewelry um there's no point in
which the audience is ever going to be
on board with the hype that this
character is trying to portray and if
the trailer were cut differently or
presented differently i think if the
music were different that would be a
huge thing if the music were like more
hyped if some of the the combat were
much more exciting
i think we would be on board it's that
it's so
awkwardly disconnected that makes it
just like it does the opposite of what
it intended to it makes you less excited
because it's like she's dramatically
over exaggerating something again i
think that this could have worked with
the exact same line said the exact same
way in a different context but i also
think
it's kind of not giving the gaming
audience enough credit um
like maybe if this spot again you still
have to fix the music you have to make
things mash together a lot better having
the music you know actually like seem
triumphant and not just like throw away
background noise but gamers have already
seen someone fighting dragons in games
we've already seen people flying we've
already seen even people talking to
inanimate objects none of those things
are even exciting for us at a base level
if you write them down like if those
were bullet points of things that you do
in the game fight jacked up beasts i'd
be like okay
so it's most video games so yeah it's
not that i think their writing is is
awful it's not that i think the voice
acting is bad um and i don't think the
game looks bad i just think that this is
a really really really poorly done video
again there are people who are like
jumping on it for negative reasons i've
seen the whole like
go woke
get broke get get work get broke
basically there are people who are just
attacking it because the protagonist of
the game is a woman of color which is
ridiculous and i'm not on board with and
i don't want any of those people to
think i align with them i do think the
game looks cool i think the protagonist
will be fine i think releasing this
trailer has made people dislike her by
default because she seems nuts
and she's clearly marketing use
marketing for marketing don't ruin your
protagonist for marketing it's just oh
it could have worked
i just maybe it was an editing problem
maybe they were rushed i've seen a lot
of people meme this and some of the
memes are very funny i'm not sure if
somebody's like tried to fix the trailer
though
i wouldn't be surprised
if somebody's trying to fix it because
this tweet went like
the ratio of this
it's eight
thousand eight hundred quote tweets oh
my gosh that's a lot um and yeah a lot
of people being very upset
in a way that i don't agree with someone
said why can't the dialogue just be
normal the dialogue is very normal and i
actually think that's the problem with
it
she's just a regular human who got
transported to a world that that kind of
is how you would react it just doesn't
sell it to us at all
that said i'm also not saying that the
writing is good um it's just not
actually what i think the problem is i
think the problem is just a massive
i keep using the word marketing
disconnect happy to talk about it
because it is interesting and uh no
disrespect to the team who had to put
that together i'm sure it's
been
wild they probably have like an insane
number of impressions but
obviously a lot of negativity of course
it's just on twitter and i always want
to remind people
twitter is not the gaming community
twitter is so small twitter is not the
world people forget that all the time
like it's not like everyone ever has
seen this it's not like most gamers have
even seen this
most gamers will never see this little
twitter spot um they will have no
knowledge of what this is so i don't
know that it's gonna have a huge impact
on the game but for the people who have
seen it on twitter three million views
it's not a small amount you could sell
three million copies of a square enix
game they may have to like put an effort
to fix their protagonist it is time to
talk about keeps if you didn't already
know keeps is a subscription service
that helps men keep their hair there's
no magic cure for boldness but you can
prevent hair loss from happening in the
first place and the earlier you take
action the more hair you'll keep keeps
is for you if you're interested in
doctor recommended hair loss treatments
they offer clinically proven treatments
to combat the symptoms of hair loss of
course there is nothing wrong with being
bold but if this is something that
you're insecure about know that there
are options that are doctor recommended
clinically proven and affordable so once
you sign up your daily supply of
treatment arrives every three months at
half the cost of a pharmacy and all
treatment plans are personalized and
doctor recommended keeps also offers 24
7 expert support the treatment plans
come with a year of unlimited doctor
messaging with keepsa's network of
expert medical advisors prescribers and
care specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality so
whether you're looking to prevent hair
loss stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered easily subscribe to
keeps and get refill reminders so you'll
never run low and talk to physicians who
will help you select the right products
and treatments for your specific
condition and hair goals hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com alana pierce or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash alana pierce now
back to the video to some other
questions hey a lot of just wondering
how you feel about the rumors that
hogwarts legacy has been delayed to 2023
to get out of the way of god of war
ragnarok
was it tim gettys that started this
rumor it might have been uh there are a
million reasons a game can be delayed
it's like that's
a hypothesis that is probably like
pretty low on the likelihood hypothesis
chain of why games get delayed it is
possible but i think infinitely more
likely
that it's delayed because it needs more
time that the game needs more polish i
do suspect god of war ragnarok will be a
big juggernaut seller of a video game
this year i hope you were excited about
it you should be excited about it and
certainly there are still games that
like it would make sense to move out of
the way of but this stuff tends to be
more on a publisher by publisher basis
that said
it actually most commonly happens um
from the things that i know to be fact
under the same publisher so if uh one
game is getting delayed because it needs
more time and then that pushes it up too
close to another game say i use ea for
example
ea probably wouldn't do this but for an
example say they have to delay a game
into may where previously it was
supposed to be in march because it needs
the extra time for polish and there was
another game that was supposed to
release in april they might push the
april game out to september just to
avoid doubling down on two games being
in the same quarter where they want them
to be separate for their sales
productions that is much more common and
more likely again it's possible but uh
these are also two just very big ips god
of war and
harry potter are two very big ips both
games are going to succeed regardless
croc b gator said question for the next
q a
reviews for xenoblade 3 weren't out
until a week ago anyway do you think
with all the praise xenoblade 3 is
getting it could be nominated for game
of the year i personally love the
xenoblade series and monoliths pro
workplace practice as a whole so it'd be
nice to see them recognized
i think i've spoken about this before
but i firmly believe that there are game
of the year games
and that
xenoblade
is not one of them
and this is like very reflective of just
humans having very specific biases and
things that they remember and things
that they like very much cling onto i
don't think it's a flaw with the idea of
game of the year it's why you shouldn't
take game of the year seriously though
like
they should still exist outlets should
still be able to vote on them you should
still have your own that you stand by
and none of them should ever be taken as
gospel title game of the year like it's
the only one that matters because they
are just people's opinions and people's
opinions are biased of course i do not
think xenoblade or xenoblade um is game
of the year even despite the really good
reviews um
i i have no doubt that it'll make some
lists it'll for sure get nominated for
uh rpg category but there's just such a
specific type of game that wins at the
different award shows or from the
different outlets they're always
different i was really surprised by ign
giving it to forza horizon last year
that's a massive surprise last year was
actually really across the board my
favorite game last year my game of the
year was inscription which i think also
won at the game developers choice awards
which is pretty reflective of how those
get voted on it's like there's a
game award show for everybody if you're
talking about the game awards it has got
to be something that is huge in scale
almost always photo realistic big budget
um and dramatic elden ring
is a game of the year title the way it
looks the drama of it all which is even
down to the the voice acting it's pretty
it's huge in scale it feels like it has
a very weighty impact on the medium
there are things that i'm always like
man this really should have won or this
really should have been nominated or
like it sucks that this genre or this
kind of game or this franchise doesn't
uh get more love there but i really
strongly feel that there's like an
archetype and in a lot of cases as well
like where something like god of war is
concerned which did win obviously red
dead redemption 2 won a lot of awards
that year as well both fantastic games
they were like the two that were hotly
contested the last of us part two is
another example it tends to be things
that uh resonate with people emotionally
i think even elden ring can do that and
sakura could do that because they
resonate with you emotionally due to the
difficulty where there's a challenge you
have to get emotionally invested you get
frustrated you get angry you have a huge
high when you're done with beating
whatever boss you found difficult that
still counts as an emotional resonance
and that's not to say that xenoblade
doesn't have that i'm like kind of
removing myself from that conversation
now but that definitely seems to be a
key
thing is they have to like really sit
with people emotionally so that you will
think about them the whole 12 months i
do also think cult of the lamb is in for
a pretty good shot this year at some of
the award shows it's really polished
it's really stylish um
but it's still very unique so yeah i
don't know it's probably very rambly but
um
as you say in your comment here croft v
gator i know they tend to be nice and
very long
and i think that is a big part of the
problem i don't imagine it will be
nominated for game of the year but i
could see it getting other categories
and it yeah it's just a weird part of
humans you can't
if we can't discern the best game it's
so hard to do that everyone's going to
disagree we all have different metrics
we all have different things that we
weigh up like in terms of importance
even if you try to be as objective as
possible music is going to be more
important to one person than the other
we can't remove bias we're not capable
of it so i think people just have to
find some other like very big factor and
i think emotion tends to be it again not
saying then i isn't emotional of course
it is but the fact that it's very long
and generally pretty niche works against
it and that's why
game awards don't take them seriously
they exist as a celebration of video
games and not as any definitive rule it
is more interesting if we all have
different answers as well wicked raven
said who is your favorite female gaming
character my favorite female character
in video games is ayane from dead or
alive uh also a ninja gaiden i've always
been
a very big fan of ayani if you don't
know who i'm talking about you might
recognize her here you go she's super
cool
i like the charm and i also just loved
her in ninja gaiden
she also hot because of course she is
this is ninja gaiden 3 version um well
she's a playable character she's a
protagonist and i have this statue uh
but it broke otherwise i definitely have
soft spots for um jade from beyond good
and evil and joanna dog from perfect
dark but when i think about those two
characters it's much more
because they were big parts of my
childhood than because i necessarily
like them as characters i don't even
feel like i remember them as characters
that well i feel like i thought they
were cool but i don't even really know
who they are
and that is it
for this month's q a everybody like i
said if you have any gaming questions
for the next one leave them below if you
want to ask questions about anything
else that is not directly related to
video games those will go on my other
channel which i will also leave in the
description below i will see you guys
next time bye